- Das ist ein sehr, sehr
abwechslungsreicher Beruf
und er ist auch ein sehr
anspruchsvoller Beruf.
Man hat mit Trinkwasser zu tun,
das ist Lebensmittel Nummer eins,
man hat mit Energien zu tun,
mit Gas, mit Öl, mit Pellets,
mit Wärmepumpen,
modernsten Techniken.
- Man sollte auf jeden Fall
Spaß am Handwerk haben
und auch Spaß an groben Arbeiten,
aber auch Spaß an filigranen Arbeiten,
weil dieses kommt alles zusammen.
Und das von Minute eins an.
- Ein guter Anlagenmechaniker
muss logisch denken,
muss in Mathematik ganz gut sein
und muss im Prinzip auch
Spaß am Handwerk haben
und auch mit seinen
Händen arbeiten können.
- Die Ausbildung dauert dreieinhalb
Jahre und ist aufgeteilt
in schulische und praktische Arbeiten.
Man hat immer zwei oder einen
Tag in der Woche Schule
und den Rest ist man mit den
Kollegen unterwegs auf den Baustellen.
- Erstmal als Anlagenmechanikergeselle,
wenn man die Ausbildung fertig hat,
ist man Geselle. Da kann man auf
jeden Fall im Kundendienst arbeiten,
man kann auf Baustellen arbeiten,
man kann im Neubau arbeiten,
man kann sich natürlich
auch weiterentwickeln.
Man kann noch seinen Bachelor machen,
man kann seinen Master machen,
man kann seinen Meister machen,
man kann seinen Techniker machen.
Es gibt vielfältige
Entwicklungsmöglichkeiten
gerade in unserem Beruf.
- Mir gefallen am meisten
die Badsanierungen,
weil man da von Minute eins bei den groben
Arbeiten schon ganz genau arbeiten muss,
sonst wird das Endergebnis nicht
dementsprechend, wie es gewünscht ist.
Und das ist halt dieses Faszinierende,
dass man trotz ziemlich grober Arbeit
und Staub und Lärm und Dreck
schon extrem genau arbeiten muss.
Das erfordert eine hohe Konzentration.